hello I'm a nostalgia critic guy
remember it so you don't have to you
know we don't review enough
environmentally aware films do we come
back come back I assure you this
annoying environmental film has lots of
big difference from all the other
annoying environmental film this one has
Michael Crawford hey hey come back there
come back here stop look out horn this
was a lot of force
[Music]
yep I guess the early 90s really had a
freakout about destroying the
environment that isn't worth saving but
watching this shit makes me want to burn
down five unprotected rainforests and
smoke three endangered species just to
even it out and you might as well add
this movie to the lid it's stupid it's
predictable it has a helium balloon
Michael Crawford in it it's a delight so
let's sum up this movie's message by
applying appropriate visuals this is
once upon a forest so what kind of story
would once upon a Ford be if it didn't
start out once upon a Ford Bell ah
we're in secretive man too quick hi oh
you're Eric Idle there you are
yes Daddy see you later
love you me too Abigail I love me too
yeah so this is Abigail she's off to
school with her friend a hedgehog named
Russell a mole named Edgar and a badger
named Michelle we buy a young Elizabeth
Ross from Mad Men I am so high you'll
need to be to give her this tell him it
isn't mine thought you're right she
really stays off to school though as
much as force specifically chosen for
whatever reason kids sitting around
listening to that high-pitched bothering
Hello Dolly don't take another step
this is Cornelius here you welcome he
played as I said before by Broadway
sensation Michael Crawford now some
consider him a gifted musical genius
mothers say he's pretentiously over the
top but one thing's for sure though he's
a comedian possible prepare to be amazed
well what do you have to say you're
lucky Gerard Butler things worse than
you no no no no no no no about this my
life look one day I shall build it full
fine
I want a flight now free maybe selling
your concept called perfect Abigail you
know there's only so much whimsy that
you can put into every word you say I
mean does he talk this way with
everything else he does oh no I'm out of
toilet paper
I let's go to the store well I have a
log and I really need to talk
whew it's far too delicate for furlings
oh yeah all the children in this film by
the way are called furrowing doesn't
help you to Berlin sighing sorry
darlings where the fantasy films all
your trouble just saying the word tis
it's always furling or younglings or
shia laboof you call what they are kids
no Fehlings poop
[Music]
great whoa what good long green wait
honk honk we hope Oh gray Hawk coming
home Great Hall increase home don't get
worried
look what you've done
[Music]
now you cannot ever be please
so despite the setback Cornelius decides
to still teach them the lesson for the
day which surprisingly is not making
their radii now what is this funny
oh well Cornelius car did you know it's
bark can be used to cure rheumatism
rheumatism yes what is it with her
averages I really like to know oh I know
rheumatism makes you wonder when the
weather gets down call it again
Wow well that's our first big wild
moment kids looking at a piece of bark
although don't give away the climax
where they come across a half urinated
pineco earnings we shall go home but I
know if you are not going to take this
ramble serious did he really just call
his own
be sure ramble but even he knows what
he's saying is 100% bullshit it's not
very encouraging when your teacher
acknowledges or what he's saying is
totally pointless now children so would
you like me to provoke him all about my
uncontrollable bowel syndrome this
ground isn't normal card it's not gonna
friend telling you stop calling him that
it sounds like a Rachel for
Russell it's rare that a furling
survives an encounter with the monster
that is a good name for it it's rare
that a Range Rover doesn't burn you into
rabbit roadkill that you are a bunch of
little hurried halt I want you to forget
this place
what was it really Cornelius man yeah
man has always oh you know what
I'm sick of it I'm tired of putting man
down all the time what the hell are all
with you people
oh I like man I'm a man and I don't like
how we always have to say what about the
rat holes we are hey you know it's
dangerous you know what's really
frightening to everybody edible they eat
people have sharp teeth and carry
several diseases if you should stay away
from anything say away from them look at
this poor woman she's doing god I don't
know what but the lion doesn't like it
hello evil bad I want to kill you they
don't make films about what a bunch of
dicks they are they just fucking eat you
animal you better eat them before they
eat you look at right now fuck outta
nowhere here's the big surprise Oh
[Music]
getting dead collision all right Abigail
Russell you pedal first
perhaps we should see a song oh oh oh
your boat gently down the stream
what are fortunately justice Cornelius
was talking about the evils of man what
a behold the man shows up that's a
truckload of poisonous gas gets into an
accident and spread through the force
[Music]
oh please mother of God tell me that
green gas has the singing voice of Tim
Curry cream mmm mmm crawling from aiya
you smell my god whisper parenting's
return they see that everyone has a bend
in their hole and some didn't even make
it out alive
Michelle no bullying there's a cyclic
gas in there
we had Kokubo just beholding at home
we're not waiting clever your clothes
so what the girl finds that Michelle's
parents didn't survive Oh No that is so
sad we should do a montage of all the
times we see him to show just what
impact they've left on us okay
she also comes across Michelle who
apparently has passed out
come on we all know it's not the first
time in Elizabeth Ross character has
breezed in something hazardous
hi I'm so high I wish I was but Abigail
gets her out and they try to figure out
how to save her in the meantime
Cornelius tell fastenings exactly what
business a long time ago I lived far
away in a place called Willowbrook they
heard the sound mother and father told
us to run we got out but mother and
father but he didn't boy this was all
about the parenting badger death isn't
it if you're a badger you help me wipe
your asses gasps that was nothing I
could do for my mother or father ma'am I
understand most people in Cornelius at
Babel ought to get ma'am beware the
Beast man for he is the devil's pawn but
there is something you can do for
Michelle I need special plans and
everything you know matters time then
you must find another another meadow
there's no choice you only have two days
time even with us right I wish I could
but I dare not leave her side uh
wouldn't it make more sense if you went
looking for the plants and the children
stayed with Michelle obviously this is
incredibly dangerous so why risk moving
the lives of four children instead of
one I mean seriously why don't you a
grown adult go on this mission it does
sacrificing people no children up up up
yeah we're with it
hmm my herself no you'll have each other
which pretty much means you'll be by
yourself you'll want an early start now
get some sleep
and if you dream dream of better times
for Michelle and that board you see them
telling them what's a dream sky a bit of
a dickhole sorry it's just he didn't
even ask them to do this or start out by
saying I'll go and then maybe let one of
them volunteer instead no she just
forced them to endanger their lives kind
of a jerk off
I thought about need weep again Oh
rheumatism yet and of course it wouldn't
be a Michael Crawford well anything
unless he stopped you barely need just
one beat of mine and here's where people
usually split on Crawford you either
love his singing or you're really
annoyed by it but I think we can all
agree that it goes all over the place
starting from a high-pitched
soothingness no matter imma be all nice
and done and then in a millisecond
changing to a shaky low tone leave
doctrine Beale
whether I thing like this holy voice
exhausted he's away Artie with a bag
that into me
his scenery sounds like a two minute
long side
[Music]
hey mr. Crawford there out of you who at
the grocery store wanna guess I'll go
with Crisco
[Music]
well either way he only gets one song as
the story will continue with ascending
going into the wilderness to find a cure
they come across an open field where a
dangerous owl look out for prey and of
course he buys it well one down two more
to go dude all the kids will be dead
thanks to Cornelius's cowardliness but
hey fat but it's okay
Abigail uses a magnifying glass to make
your teeth look bigger and they actually
scares the elf
wife is the whole animals like furling
ass after they escape they try to get
some shut-eye for the nights a little
heads their strength in the morning
suddenly they hear something in the
distance I'm sorry
another movie seems to be passing
through coming to Donald
[Music]
so it sort of takes a while to figure
out what's going on but it looks like a
bunch of these birth or having a funeral
for another bird that hasn't died yet
see why it's confusing what actually is
going on is the birds are saying goodbye
to a younger bird a desing if you really
because he got stuck in the mud and
seems to slowly be sinking and when I
say slowly I mean not moving at all it's
not like the parents could just bring
him food and still look after I'm not oh
he's a goner throw the funeral even
though he's alive see the course oh let
the kids figure out a way to get the
little bird out so this calls for
several minutes of music Oh Pat Wow
we are
[Music]
that was pointless
both the birds are kind enough to say
were another meadow life for them to
find the plants they're looking for the
only path lives that way across a
cursive ground over which my flock will
not even fly that is on account of our
rheumatism so we try to make it further
but come across a bunch of bulldoze
there's an other machines that they
confused for yellowdragon but they
managed to escape and efficiently do
come across another mess tech it even
has other animals in it very just here
to steal our food no we're just looking
for my work and eyebright we need to
smell the sick badgers why would a mole
a mouse and a hedgehog wanna help us a
foul-smelling worm-eating
good-for-nothing badger ha ha ha hey
look at all the eyebright that's right
they come across the line one half of
the plants that they needed so where's
the other plant located oh no one in oak
tales ever been able to reach it I know
how to get up there please
cornelius flapper wingamathing russell
good thinking uh yeah just take the plan
for a device that took months and months
to build and make it ten times bigger in
just a matter of a few hours yes I'd
like to see that watch aw fuck
okay there's MacGyver and then there's
God and this is my god / there is no way
you can do this so on top of getting it
to fly they can also steer the thing
honey
I wonder how the mechanics of leaves
sticks and animal dung commands put
together complete aviation control so
Abigail tries to grab the plant but miss
luckily edgers there to save her but
they come across a major problem it's no
use now come on what's gone we failed
no we haven't happened what's the plan
try to commit suicide it just happened
to land on the plane what the hell oh
well kiss the sanding pick their plants
and decide to go home Wow getting some
good height on that thing aren't they in
fact that makes a question if they could
build this thing in just a few hours why
didn't they build it before they left on
this adventure women have come a
travelling time in half if it wasn't for
Neely is building while the children
were asleep lemme get aa to the H to the
e to the U and a Tizen so the kids land
and finally make it back home with the
planks to make the cure
[Music]
it's okay it turns out you just need
some aspirin how are you my fuzzies
you're back did you get that up but it
turns out more shit is after them as it
seems evil man is looking for them
outside
after exposing some mole frontal nudity
we see that Edgar gets caught as man
will no doubt sacrifice into that
solution God there you go little fella
what's this man who is in a balloon okay
clearly you have no idea our early 90s
animated environmental films work rule
number one man is the devil
anything not man is good and your movie
must boss you got call those down but
number one is still a B so after
wrapping her in a slim suit they try
giving her the s and wait until morning
to see if it works
but sadly it doesn't look like she's
waking up
[Music]
mama
of course the missing ingredient
Pikachu tears mixed with a heart of
Inspector Gadget well imagine moonbeams
drop down during the chanting of we care
as your take your from the Genesis
planet mercy Oh Michelle my child you're
alright
[Music]
you have changed so much these possible
days you're no longer my furlings
you are burn nature and once you know it
all the family members come back at the
exact same time to collect their
children oh what a happy day coming back
not all idea
that's a fucking downer talk about
captain buzzkill the other happy endings
do you ruin with your sad awkward facts
whoa I just won the lottery
yes the 9/11 still happened I just
nothing will ever be the same again what
I'm clinging well my dear if we all work
hard to save dapplewood eight will
defend me my mom and dad will come back
all right
no dear they're dead and buried well not
you're buried Hey I just figured out a
fun activity for you to do tomorrow
so that was once upon a fourth choice
and I be spike the clot Fern Gully
Daisy this isn't the worst of those
environmental films as it does try to
take a few more chances while keeping a
parent dead and not making man entirely
evil but it doesn't do those elements
especially well the characters are
pretty bland the animation is okay but
nothing Bill Murray and it's just the
same message that every other
environmental film in the 90s has I'm
not horrible it's pretty weak they just
didn't feel like it brought anything
that any other film hasn't brought
before it's just a weak weak bill so you
see it can kill you to hear another
environmental review bit I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh horrible
a rheumatism